Well, hello everybody.
Hello.
How are you? Thank you for being here as a part of our Reducing
Research Friction: How Scientists and Survivors Can Accelerate
Progress. Really appreciate everybody joining at the end of a
long day.
And we have one other speaker that will be joining us, so she
will probably be, hopefully, joining in the next few minutes.
But we'll go ahead and get started. I'm Angie Davis.
I'm the CEO of Fight Colorectal Cancer.
We're a national advocacy organization
focused on policy change, research, and empowering
patients to tell their story. Really, this has been really
exciting to talk about as it relates to research advocacy because
we were founded by Nancy Roach, one of the
pioneers in research advocacy back in the day.
And we really thought, as an organization, as part of
our mission, that patients needed to be at the table with
researchers to do exactly what is listed on this graphic, which
is identify research priorities, design protocols, and write
grants, apply for funding, recruit patients from
the very beginning, conduct studies together, share those results,
and disseminate those outcomes at scale.
So that was the framework for what I think is
now what is known as research advocacy and popularized by many
organizations, and I think they've done an amazing job of
taking that forward across cancer sites.
As far as next slide,
I am going to say that Kristen is not here,
but Kristen Dahlgren is a breast cancer patient and she's the co-lead on
this panel. So what we are going to do is
actually skip her presentation for right now, and I
am going to introduce Sharon, who is the CEO
and founder of
Trials of Color. And so I'm going to invite you to come up and share what
you've done and your perspective on clinical trials and engagement.
Okay.
Good afternoon, everyone. Thank you so much for joining
us.
Let me see if I can pull up my slides. You want me to go ahead and get started?
Yeah.
Completely?
Okay, but
my slides are... Oh.
Okay, I believe someone will have to help me because-
He's going to bring them up.
He's going to bring them up? Okay.
So it'll be Sharon's slide deck.
Trials of Color.
Okay.
Missing Voices, Missing Opportunity:
Fixing Cancer Research for the Underserved Patient.
Good evening, ladies and gentlemen.
I am Sharon Rivera-Sanchez, the CEO and the founder
of Trials of Color. We are based out of Richmond,
Virginia.
I have no
financial relationship to disclose.
The 37-day price, the Petersburg,
Virginia story. Petersburg, Virginia is a
town about 35 miles south of Richmond,
Virginia,
home to some of the state highest rate of
cancer mortality. Petersburg, Virginia
population is about 44,000. Black
African American, 74% to 77%.
I once lived in Petersburg, Virginia.
I still have family members that live in Petersburg, Virginia.
Clarence Hannon lived in Petersburg, Virginia.
He never had a colonoscopy. From the time he was
diagnosed with colorectal cancer, he passed
37 days later.
Clarence Hannon was, and still is, my brother.
When the right voices are missing from the
conversation, the science is incomplete.
And in cancer research, incomplete science
costs lives, with more numbers from the underserved
community.
Bring your attention to the picture where the four empty
chairs are right there.
The empty chairs at the table serve as a powerful
reminder of the voices still missing from the conversation,
the patient and community members whose lives are
at the heart of our work. Now, if you look at the
next picture, we have included
the community members, survivors, patient, and
caregivers.
Research and clinical data from 2024 to
2025 confirmed that the underserved community,
especially African American community, are significant
more prone to being diagnosed with cancer at a
late stage compared to the general
population. When we look at breast
cancer, I'm a breast cancer survivor,
our incident rate is 5% lower,
but our mortality rate is 38%
to 48% higher.
If you look at the graphics here, hysteria barrier to
early detection, late stage, as I mentioned,
screening desert, high insurance deductible,
or delayed care. In the middle, we was talking about
the breast cancer, 5% lower incident,
38% to 40% more likely to die.
The last slide is talking about screening with colorectal
cancer. African Americans, 10% to
15% behind in
thatSo the expertise of
lived experience. Data tell you what,
but lived experience tell you why.
Lived experience is a form of expertise that a
spreadsheet can never capture.
Data can't tell you the story of the
37-day battle of my brother.
Can't tell you about, I'm in not one,
not two, not three, not four,
but I'm currently active in my fifth clinical
trial. However, I dropped out of two.
Now, unless I disclose that to the PI or nurse
navigator,
they don't know why. The data can't tell you why I dropped out.
It just tells you I dropped out.
We must be intentional about who is in the room, and
more important, who is being heard.
To have a good outcome, and I would go as far as to
say, to have a great outcome, we
need a survivor at the table, caregiver,
trusted messenger, and of course, the loved one.
If these voices aren't at the table, the outcome will
only serve those who are.
The trusted messenger model, what we use in
Petersburg, however, you can use this anywhere.
How we increase awareness in a community like Petersburg,
you must think outside the box. It's not just about
spreading awareness, it's about who is spreading
awareness. When a trusted messenger
is included in research conversation
at the beginning, they can translate medical jargon
into community action.
Thinking outside the box.
I'm not a spring chicken.
Our team is not spring chicken. But we went out
and got licensed to drive motorcycles.
Had no intentions of how to hold the thing up.
But if you see this picture here,
these are called three-wheelers, slingshots.
So we rode in a parade in Petersburg.
We actually led that parade, of course, with police
escort. It was a big community event, and it was
very successful because it gave us an
opportunity to give out fit kits and to talk to
the community.
A holistic model for health equity.
We need strategic partnership, funding,
mobile access, boots on the ground.
The four pillars of impact, your survivor,
the caregiver, the trusted messenger, and of course,
the loved ones.
From data to partnership, don't just study our community.
Stand with us, fund us, partner with us, and
include us. Thank you so much.
All right. Thank you, Sharon.
My name is Julie Fleshman. I am the president and CEO of the
Pancreatic Cancer Action Network, also known as PanCAN.
I joined the organization now 26 years ago after
my father was not feeling well. Back pain,
unexplained weight loss, jaundice,
and unfortunately, he was eventually diagnosed with pancreatic cancer.
He was 52 years old, and he only lived four months after his
diagnosis, and I was mad. At that time, there
was really literally nothing being done for this
disease. You could count on one hand the number of
institutions that were doing anything in pancreatic
cancer research. And I was just really lucky, the
Pancreatic Cancer Action Network was founded at about that same time, and I was
hired as the first employee in 2000.
And I've now had this incredible opportunity
to be a part of this amazing community over the last
two and a half decades. And just last week, you may have
heard the big news. Revolution Medicines, who was doing the
first ever Phase III
trial for pancreatic cancer patients with a
drug targeting KRAS,
announced positive results, and there is a lot of
activity in the KRAS space, and I think really we are
entering a new era of treatment options for
pancreatic cancer patients, and I just couldn't be more excited.
And I don't think we would be in this moment today
if it hadn't been for PanCAN, if it hadn't been for advocates, if it hadn't
been for what we've done over the last two and a half decades to get us here.
So many of you know, two out of every five
Americans will be diagnosed with cancer in their lifetime.
These are sobering statistics. That's why we're here at
AACR.
It's also, to me, a reminder why the government,
the federal investment in cancer research is
so critically important.
Ultimately, that research leads to better
outcomes for patients, but that research
also fuels
research projects, jobs, the
ecosystem that we have across this country
to develop new drugs, to do research in labs.
Those dollars are fueling medical institutions all across
the country.And so pancreatic
cancer is a great example of a disease where we
need to do more.
Pancreatic cancer is currently the third leading cause of cancer death in the
United States, and it's expected to become the second leading cause of cancer
death in 2030, in just four years.
Over 67,000 Americans will be diagnosed with pancreatic cancer this year.
When I started doing this two and a half decades ago, that number was 24,000.
The five-year survival rate today is 13%.
It was 4% back then, so we've made progress.
We're moving in the right direction, but we all can agree that
13% is completely unacceptable.
And so what did we need to do to make this change, to
start moving that five-year survival rate in the
direction that we want it for patients?
And this really just shows you the outcome of advocating for
increased federal resources for this
disease. Back in 1999, when PanCAN was founded,
the National Cancer Institute was only investing
$17.3 million in pancreatic cancer research all
across the country. Remember I said there were only a handful of
institutions doing pancreatic cancer research? You can imagine it.
There was only $17.3 million being invested in the
disease. And, the five-year survival rate was just
4%. And through our advocacy efforts, educating
members of Congress about pancreatic cancer, about
cancer research in general, and going up on the Hill and
bringing patients and researchers and telling the
story about how we could do so much better if there was
more funding. And so we've slowly seen those dollars increase,
specifically for pancreatic cancer.
In 2022, we now have old data because the NCI is not
able to share their data publicly anymore.
But with the most recent data we have is from 2022,
$222 million now being invested in pancreatic
cancer research from the federal government.
There also is a program at the Department of Defense that, again, PanCAN
advocates helped to create. And then, of course, we're also
raising dollars and increasing the number of the
private investment that is being made in this disease.
And so today, the five-year survival rate is 13%.
And like I said at the beginning, I think we're on the tip of
many more advances to come in the next five to 10
years. And so what PanCAN did was we built a movement.
We took a disease where no one was talking about it.
Nobody really knew anything about it except that it was really bad.
Patients and families had no support system.
There was nowhere to go for information or resources.
There was no community. And researchers didn't have
a champion. They didn't have a cheerleader.
They didn't have anyone saying, "Keep it up. Keep going.
You're on the right track. How can we support and how can we help you?" And so
PanCAN built a community across the country.
We have 57 volunteer affiliates. And our
volunteers, one of the things that we ask them to do
is to advocate to their members of Congress about why the
federal investment in pancreatic cancer and cancer research in
general is so incredibly important.
So I don't know if you remember Randy Pausch. This was back in 2008.
He was a professor at Carnegie Mellon,
and the normal procedure that happened
when someone retired was that they would give their last lecture.
And Randy, unfortunately, had to give his last lecture because he
was dying of pancreatic cancer. He had three small
children.
You can see the picture there in the background, his three kids and
his wife.
And so I feel very lucky still to this day that
PanCAN was able to connect with him, and he agreed to come to
Capitol Hill and testify in front of Congress
just months before he died. So he chose to use the time that he
had to help further this cause, not just for him, but
for all patients. And I think this quote, "Pancreatic cancer
is a disease I think we can beat, but it's going to take more continued courage
and funding from our government to help protect us from the
things we can't protect ourselves from." And that was
really the beginning of us raising a tremendous
amount of awareness on Capitol Hill,
getting members of Congress from both sides of the aisle as our
champions,
to help us think about how we could increase funding for pancreatic
cancer. And I'm just so proud of our community who, when we
ask them to show up, they show up.
Purple is our color, and on the day when PanCAN
advocates come to Capitol Hill, it's a sea of
purple. My story, I lost my father to pancreatic
cancer. My story is important, but my story
becomes so much more impactful when my story's
combined with all of the other stories.
The combined collective stories of our
community is what makes us so incredibly powerful
and allows us to take action and
move towards making progress.
And we don't do this alone, right? I think the part of this conversation we're
having here this evening is about engaging our stakeholder
community. It's not just about the patients and the families.
It's also about the researchers and the scientists and the
healthcare professionals who are hard at work every day treating
patients with pancreatic cancer and studying this disease.
We have a survivor council. We have a volunteer advisory council.
We have a health equity committee.
We work with biotech and industry partners.
We want all of those voices to be a part of the actions that we are
taking, whether that's up on Capitol Hill or helping to guide
our research strategy.So
Congresswoman Anna Eshoo actually retired recently.
But she
always said to us, "Your voices are important and powerful.
They're how we've been able to build this movement to what we have now." So
she was one of, I would say, our first real congressional
champions. Back in, this is around the same time as the Randy
Pouch, 2008, I remember meeting with her,
and she said to me, "Julie,
you must go get the people. You
must have the people come tell their stories.
Congress acts when the people tell us what to do.
You must go get the people." And I'll just never forget that, because
that was what it was all about. We have to get the stories, we have to get our
community, researchers, patients, families, all the
stakeholders, to come to Capitol Hill and to tell
Congress why this is so important. And the bottom line, advocacy works.
I think there's no better example of that than this last year,
when the administration was threatening to cut
biomedical research in this country by 30%.
It would've been devastating. And the advocates spoke up, and we
talked, and we went to Congress, and we made sure that they remembered
why this has always been a bipartisan issue, and why
this would be damaging to their communities and their
states if their institutions suddenly had a 30%
cut in biomedical research funding.
Howard Crawford, one of our researchers, said, "Funding opportunities for
pancreatic cancer research are already scarce, and eliminating one of the major
funding sources, even for a year, will destroy the careers of some
bright young scientists and any groundbreaking discoveries they might have made
otherwise in the years to come." So again, it was the voice of the researchers
and the patients and families talking about the impact, not
just on the end outcome, which is, of course, for patients,
but also on our scientific field. Federal funding is
critically important for building the pipeline for junior investigators, and
all of that has been threatened, quite frankly, in the last
year. And so Pancan stood up. We stood out against
what we did not believe was right. And we stood up with our
other cancer partners, with One Voice Against Cancer, with Research
America, with many of the other organizations.
Angie and I did some things together.
We really partnered together to say, "How can we make our voices even
stronger during this time?" And it, whoops.
And it was a major win. Last year, I think they're telling me to hurry up.
It was a major win. Appropriations, in the end of the day
for FY26,
there was an increase.
The Department of Defense pancreatic cancer program that had been eliminated in
FY25 was reinstated in FY26 with more money
than it had ever been funded before.
So our voices do matter. Congress does
listen. And so I really encourage everyone to
ensure that you're talking to your members of Congress, that you're
bringing your community together, that you're telling your stories, and
collectively, again, our voices have
incredible impact.
So I think I'll stop there,
hand it off to Angie.
Take it back.
And then we'll take questions at the end.
So I think you can see,
research advocacy, advocacy, when you talk about patient engagement, it's a
layered
definition. There isn't just a one size fits all when we talk about
research advocacy and patients. I love that Sharon talks about the relationship
of caregivers and your family members and what drives your why and why you show
up. And really what Julie showed is a best in
class outline of what advocacy organizations can
do over 25 years. I mean, we started when we were 12, I
think.
Right.
We don't want to age ourselves. But the fact is, there's these
layers of advocates out there and organizations that are out there that are
fighting on behalf of research scientists.
And so the reason why I wanted the word friction to be a part of
our title is that there is a level of friction when we talk about research
advocacy, because as you heard, we prioritize things that are
important to us as patients and to the people that we love and we care
about. And that may not always be aligned with the science.
But I think that when we work together and we talk and we work through it, it
does align with the science, and we do get better outcomes.
So I just want to underscore how important it is that we work through that
friction and we recognize it.
So we heard from both speakers. It's important to talk about how do we
support our advocates, our research advocates. How do we connect with them?
How do we convene them? How do we partner with them?
How do we embed them in the process?
And then how do we measure and recruit
individuals that represent our communities?
And so my section was really talking about what is this national model?
What does this look like now? Because I think back in the day, one of our
colleagues, Wendy Selig, used to always say, "We're not your
grandmother's nonprofit anymore." And there's a lot of truth to that.
We're not baking cookies out on the street
like we remember. These are really peers in cancer research,
really thinking about forward-thinking, what we can do, how can we fund it,
how can we align? And so I think when we talk about these national
organizations that are bringing people together,
these are really smart advocates who know the science, who really
want to dig into the science. And I think for me, that's really exciting.
But it's not just because you were diagnosed with cancer, you get a PhD in
science. There's a lot of investment by these individuals to give their
time, their treasure, their intellect, their skill,
and really spending time with researchers.
And I think that is so incredibly important and recognized by
the research communitySo at Fight Colorectal Cancer, I'd mentioned our
founder, Nancy Roach, her heart was in research advocacy, and
so we thought long and hard, how do we clone people who are passionate
about cancer research? So we started what we call
Research Advocacy Training and Support, and we affectionately call it our RATS
program. And they love being called rats.
But we train them from soup to nuts, like what is basic science?
What is a protocol? What is an IRB? What is
statistical analysis? For some people, they could've been a carpenter, or they
could've worked retail, or they could've been a financial analyst, but now they
have cancer, and they want to help the infrastructure of science.
And so we train them so they can engage and sit on these panels and
boards and have an effective conversation with people.
Because where we see the friction with
patients and researchers is researchers, and I love my
researchers, but are not always the patient individuals in the room.
So when we have patients sit at a table, sitting
across from a researcher, we want them to feel empowered and be able to have that
conversation, and we definitely don't want a researcher to roll their eyes at them
and go, "They don't understand how hard this is," or "How hard it is to recruit,"
or "How the protocol works," or "My institution's not going to do that."
So we want to make sure that they have that sort of credibility right off the
bat when they sit down with a researcher or a research team.
Second, we really started to build what we call our think tanks.
We build a community of researchers who are
like-minded. We bring research advocates in the room, and what we
have done is we've written reports on what is a priority for
colorectal cancer patients. And we broke it down into four different
categories. What is the etiology? What is screening and prevention?
What are better treatment options and survivorship?
And then what research priorities fall under each of those categories?
We built think tanks around that. We published a report, which I'll share
after this. And
that's, for us, part of that partnership, is how can we help
you prioritize and do the excellent work that you're already doing without
having to
poll and focus group a lot of patients?
We want to be a partner. We have the patients, we have the community, and we want
to be able to synthesize that for our scientific community.
So we partner with a lot of industry. We partner with academics.
We partner with NCI because, for colorectal cancer, NCI is the largest funder of
colorectal cancer research. Unlike some other cancers, we're the second leading
cause of cancer deaths, but I would say that the funding
opportunities for colorectal cancer hasn't matched the diagnosis
rates. We looked at the numbers at NCI, and we represent
9% of cancer deaths, and we
take in about less than 3% of the NCI budget.
So for us, fighting alongside our partners to say colorectal cancer
is very important, and we should fund it, and recently, you may have heard the news
that colorectal cancer is the leading cause of cancer deaths for those under 50.
And Becky Siegel eloquently said this, "A tsunami is coming as it
relates to colorectal cancer, and it's foreshadowing in the modeling
studies, in the studies that we're looking at, that it is coming, and we should do
something about it." And so like PanCAN, we go to The Hill.
We bring advocates to The Hill to ask for research dollars.
Over the last 20 years, we've been able to
effectively bring in $80 million towards colorectal cancer research, and we'd
love to see that number double. And we've demonstrated that advocates
are ready,
and they're ready to engage in this research process.
So, oops, I went the wrong way.
Hmm. So again, this was the earlier slide that I shared, but I just want to
identify that it starts with one, identifying the research priorities,
and that's a great opportunity for scientists who are in the room.
And just curious, who is a scientist in the room?
Okay, awesome. I just kind of wanted to see what the mix was.
But for scientists to start early and often talking to us, to
advocacy groups, how can I partner?
How can I identify someone in my community that I can work with?
Start having advocates at the table, like Sharon said.
Fill those tables with a couple advocates, a couple caregivers, to
really say, "Is this realistic? Can a patient show up three
times in a week for a blood draw? Will they want to choose a clinical
trial over standard of care?" I think those voices are really important
as you're starting to design your protocols, applying for
funding. Don't just ask us for letters of support in the last hour.
Ask us what we think and what our priorities are, and
also maybe let us read your grant before we write the letter of
support. That's always lovely. And then we love to help
recruit for clinical trials because those are really important options for our
patients. And so let us know when you're recruiting.
Let us know where you're recruiting.
Let us be a part of your strategy and your voice.
Conduct a study and share those results.
One thing that I love to hear is when scientists are talking about...
I actually think PCORI does a really good job of this, is what is the feedback loop
after you've conducted the study?
Even if it failed, even if it didn't work out, what did we learn?
How can patients
gain from your work? And then, again, use us
as a way, beyond just social media, help us help you get the
word out about your science, and how can we amplify and support
those priorities that you have alongside ours.
So I'd mentioned before, we host think tanks, and what we call our path to a
cure is our strategy. So if you are interested in where
we have prioritized the work, there's a QR code.
You can download it. But we work with scientists year-round.
We have work groups with our scientific community.
We partner with research advocates around the country, and we
continue to host these convenings.
And for us, we want to amplify what NCI is doing, what DoD is
doing, and what these large federal funders are doing by filling
this gap.
NCI is a complicated institution.
They can't just host a meeting with advocates on a dime.
They can't pivot as quickly as I wish they could, but we can help
them, and we can help inform them. And so, this is our path to a
cure.And then I wanted to share this because I know
that-- Well, I figured we would be talking to some scientists and maybe some
industry folks, and I thought this study was really interesting.
It was a modeling study that was done around what is the
value of having a patient at the table.
And that sometimes it boils down to what is the value and sort of how does that
turn into money?
And so when I looked at the study, I thought it was fascinating.
So one amendment to a protocol can delay a
trial by 90 days. And so what does that mean if it's delayed by
90 days? So that equates to over
$141,000 for that 90-day delay.
And that is
a significant amount of money.
And so if that's a phase two trial, that's what it kind of looks like, 141.
This is a modeling study, so this isn't a real study that was
reported on. For a
phase three trial,
if you have that same delay, it could cost over
$500,000.
There's a downstream effect. Recruitment's delayed, protocol's delayed,
review's delayed. All these delays have this domino effect, and it actually impacts
the amount of money that
is impacted. And I thought this was really interesting when they illustrated what
do these delays-- Because sometimes a protocol can have three to five delays.
And so if a patient could sit at the table and reduce one delay
in a phase two trial, or a patient could reduce one delay in a phase
three trial,
it can impact potentially a billion dollars when you
start looking at the long-term potential revenue an industry
partner could bring in on that clinical trial, based on
their ability to sell the drug, right, and provide that treatment
option. And I just thought it was fascinating that it actually matters if a
patient can help reduce delays for a clinical trial or a study.
And that
support goes beyond just input or patient
experience, but it actually could economically change the
dynamic. And so the other thing that I thought was interesting about this is when
we looked at it,
this particular article had pointed out, what if
industry or an institution invested $100,000
in research advocacy and making sure that patients were represented?
That's a drop in
the bucket. If we can reduce two, three, four, five delays
on a
protocol, I mean, that is valuable.
So when I saw this, I was like, it
makes so much sense for us to invest in this
conversation. This conversation about how do we engage advocacy groups?
How do we engage organizations like PanCan?
How do we engage survivors and survivors in their community?
How can we work with Sharon to make sure that it's representative of the
community and it's not just who's the closest patient in
my system that I can grab?
I think it's so important. So
this is our research team. I want to thank Kieran and April.
They do a lot of work in our research advocacy and run our
programs.
And if anybody is interested in working with them on research advocacy, they would
be more than happy to be working with you.
But for our panelists, I want to thank you for sharing your story,
sharing your passion, and the importance of research advocacy, all the way
from the community level advocacy to going to Washington, D.C.
and getting the millions of dollars we want you as scientists to have to do the
work that you're doing. So,
I thank you for being here and sharing what you're doing, and appreciate AACR
having us and sharing what research advocacy can do
to push the science forward.
So I think now we can take questions if people want to ask questions and-
Excuse me.
Yes.
I helped Kristen do the Cancer Vaccine
Initiative and get the success in 23
months. Do you want me to fill in for her?
I would love that. I mean,
if you want to just share what your thoughts are, because I think now they're going
to take it from the mic.
Because it's live-streamed as well.
If you want to just share what your experience was.
Okay.
She didn't have any slides, so.
So 23, it's exactly 24 months
now. Kristen Dahlgren
reached out to me because she had left "The Today Show," and
the reason why she resigned after being almost a
20-year
reporter and correspondent for "Today" and "NBC Nightly News"
was because she did a story on cancer vaccines.
And she was told by cancer
researchers that if money
was brought into the picture, that vaccines would be
accelerated.
If it wasn't, it would be probably 15 to 25 years.
If it was, it would be five to 10 years.
And she, as a person who'd just gone through cancer treatment and had a
young daughter, felt that
she just had to get it done, that she had to use every
contact she had from being a media person
to fast-forwarding this research.
So someone knew both of us, and that person knew that I was
deep in as a cancer advocate. My name is Sarin Rothberg,
33-year survivor, stage four cancer.
Later
figured out that it was triple negative.
Sent home to die in 2001
and reinvented my immune system. It took 18 months, and
I've been cancer-free, thank God, since July 2002.
So Kristen-
I usually make people do a wave, but it's not my
show. Anyway, so Kristen
reaches out, and
I wanted to make sure that I didn't know her from anyone, and I
just want to make sure she was a good person, and
that I'm not going to be calling up everybody, and it's somebody who wants to
leverage cancer, because for advocates in the room,
we get that. And she was so sincere on the
Zoom, and I literally said this to her,
"If God kept me alive
all these years
to help her fast-forward this research,
this is why I have the access that I have and the success that I've
had and the media presence that I have was to help
this woman, total stranger." So I said, "I need you to
get on a plane and meet me in San Diego in three
days." And she said, "Why?" And I said, "We're
going to AACR." Now, literally, she's a
new advocate, self-proclaimed,
has no experience in the advocacy world.
She's a reporter and a patient. And she goes, "What's
AACR?"
And I said, "It's something that will
fast-forward the trajectory of what we're doing by
light years." So my plane was delayed, and
she ends up in my hotel room a day before
me. I couldn't get out because of a storm.
And this poor woman must have thought, "This is a hoax.
This is a trick." But she ends up coming. Is that me?
She ends up coming, and what I do is I just
literally walk her up to every
big, powerful person in cancer that I could find on a
tag and said to them,
"Hi. Do you know Kristen Dahlgren from 'The Today Show'?
She just left her job. We're cancer survivors and
advocates, and we're going to fast-forward cancer vaccine at
lightning speed. Are you with us?"
To every person.
And we got cards. We gave
our card, her card, and I was her wing man
and wing woman, and we did this. We were
relentless. And then we sat down. We had a very
small group of people, and we said, "What's our fastest way
to success?" And so Kristen had already
mobilized one of the most powerful
oncologists, Larry Norton from Sloan Kettering, because he was her
doctor. And he was a
naysayer. He didn't think vaccines were so great, but this was his patient.
And we kept assembling doctors to
say, "We've got to solve this. We've got to solve this." And we
met with them regularly. We had a regular schedule, and we asked them
all to present to each other. So each
time we would meet on Zoom on a regularly scheduled time,
one doctor from one institution would present their
research. And Larry saw what was happening
dynamically in cancer vaccine
worldwide, and we converted him to a
cancer vaccine advocate. And he said this to
us. He said, "You're all young. I'm the oldest
person. You don't know what it was like when
chemotherapy was getting moving.
And this is what it felt like as a young
scientist when we all banded together after hours, and we
started sharing everything." And so he
became a big supporter, just really bought
into the mission that we were doing because of the
research. And we've started to learn
a lot about science. It was way
beyond our pay grade, but we started to hear,
and we were just flies on the wall as these guys would say,
"Wait a minute, my lab did that 10 years ago.
It didn't work, but we found this hack." "Okay,
we did this five years ago. Try this." And they
started to collaborate, and you saw so much
energy. So fast-forward,
we didn't love raising money. It wasn't our favorite thing, but we
got $2 million as our first donation
because
someone saw the story that Kristen went to elementary
school with in New Jersey, and that person had a
foundation, and so she made a donation to
our initiative. So again, fast-forward,
we looked at our talents of our group, and it was
really media and convening. And
so we went back to AACR, and we said, "We want to hold a
cancer summit. Are you with us?
And we want to bring together 60 of the
brightest minds in cancer,
and we want to have a two-day conference." And
because of
the media connections, we got a commitment, and
we asked patients who had been
recipients of cancer vaccines that were cancer-free to
come to New York and be part of this media blitz
that we were going to do with the doctors.
And it was really a compelling moment
cancer vaccine,
because we were going to bring everybody together and really
take over New York City. But mother nature had another plan,
and there was a massive snowstorm, and so
we
asked the patients not to come. We canceled all the media
opportunities, and the doctors ended up going
virtual. AACR helped us pivot everyone to virtual,
and there were a few people who ended up sneaking into New
York, so we had a really small hybrid community.
And, we actually have one of the sponsors in the
room.
Oh, that's great.
Just want to acknowledge you. But fast-forward that-
I hate to interrupt. I just want to make sure that others get a chance
to-
Okay.
I don't know if anybody-
I'll finish the story because-
Okay, fantastic
... it's really big. So, that was such a compelling
summit that we were told that
this was so compelling that it was being
fast-forwarded as an initiative, completely
fast-tracked. And that was the end of
January.
A roadmap crew started meeting in February, and on
March 16th, Kristin and I were told to get on
a private Zoom. And on that Zoom, we
watched one of our main scientists present the findings of our
summit, and in that private meeting from Washington,
Dr. Littai, the director of the NCI, made an
announcement that cancer vaccine was going to
get a $200 million fast-tracked
initiative, a public-private partnership.
And Kristin and I literally were jumping up and down,
and that's where we are. And I want to say, that was
one person
in the world who decided that day, on
the air of "The Today Show," on the couch, that she would not
stop until this was fast-forwarded because cancer
vaccines were in
the
doldrums. There was really nothing going on there,
at mass scale. And so, that's the story.
I wish Kristin were here to tell it herself.
I know some people in the room who got cancer vaccines
who are brilliant and alive and major
advocates and,
what you all do is amazing, and what this win
did was a win for every single advocate in this room, and
every single researcher in this convention.
Thank you for sharing that. I appreciate it.
It definitely is like a
picture of how powerful advocate stories and passion
when they align with the science, and it's
just really a great example of that.
Does anybody else have any questions?
Sorry, I probably shouldn't clear my throat into the microphone.
Steve Schneible with Cancer Research Catalyst.
Thank you very much for the excellent talk.
On the other side of advocacy, obviously, research, we all
know, is of paramount importance, but if you were to look at a map
of NCI designated cancer centers in the US,
it's a sparse map. There is a lot
of variability on what kind of treatment and how
plugged in, so to speak, clinicians may be.
So, what do you think the role of cancer research advocates
might be in ensuring not just continued
investment in progress, but
an improvement in the reliability of cancer
treatment throughout the United States, ideally the world,
and making sure that the patients everywhere have access to the latest research
developments? Thank you.
I can go first if you want.
So, at Fight Colorectal Cancer, we saw that, and
one thing that I thought was fascinating was the World Health Organization had put
out a report on breast cancer, and they had looked at what is good quality of care
for breast cancer patients. And they had picked very specific measures for
that. And I thought to myself, I was like, "Why have we not,
as a community, defined what good quality of care?" Because to your point,
there's this desert between cancer centers, depending
on where you live and what your ZIP code is.
What do I need to tell these cancer centers what good quality of care
needs to look like? So, we actually partnered with data
scientists, looked at real-world data and claims data,
to see
where are those gaps and what are those functional levers within hospital
systems we could push on to help improve quality of care for
colorectal cancer patients. So we define them as, in the screening and
prevention spaces, 80% screened in your community, and then
within 90 days, a follow-up. I will tell you, our scientific community
says 200 days. We're saying 90 days follow-up
colonoscopy.
80% of those eligible for biomarker testing get biomarker testing.
80% of those who are eligible for genetic testing should get
genetic testing, and patients who are diagnosed with colorectal cancer should
get treatment, any types,
chemotherapy, radiation, or surgery, within six weeks.
We define those as changing the trajectory of that person's
care if we were able to meet those goals.
And for us, we really had to dig into real-world data and see where
those gaps were because when we looked at just the follow-up colonoscopy,
so if a patient was diagnosed, they had a positive stool test,
and they needed to have a follow-up colonoscopy, and let's say we waited 200
days. What we saw in the claims data, that after 90 days-
We no longer saw that patient. That patient did not come back into the system.
And so those are the systems changes we
felt were really important for us when we started looking at
those specific cancer centers. And Kristen, just three
minutes.
Hi. Oh my gosh, I am so sorry.
Oh, no. It's okay.
There's no place better than a medical conference, though, to say, I had
an ocular migraine
and I couldn't see until my meds kicked in, so I was laying down and
then... Yeah, so apologies. Hi, everyone.
No worries. Actually-
Sorry
... you had a
friend-
I know
... that shared your story.
I always send a backup just in case something happens, and
Sharon's a wonderful friend and communicator, so thank you
for doing that, and tell me how I can jump in and help at the last minute.
Excellent. I think Julie was going to jump in on a question.
Yeah.
And we're talking about with NCI Cancer Centers, there are
gaps and deserts between NCI Cancer Centers.
How can we work together to kind of identify-
Yeah
... address that. But Julie? Go ahead, Julie.
Sure. So I think one of the ways that PanCAN is
trying to address that is through our patient services program.
So it's basically a call center, an information line
where patients and families can call in and get connected to a
trained case manager, who then can provide them with
really anything that they're looking for, from finding a specialist,
to finding a clinical trial, to diet and nutrition
information, or whatever it is that somebody is looking for.
That service, of course, is available free of charge.
Someone can call back multiple times.
But one of our challenges is to ensure that we're reaching every
patient, and that every patient, no matter where they live and who they are, knows
about our services. And so that, I think, is a continual challenge
that we continue to work on. African Americans, as one
example, have the highest incidence of pancreatic cancer
compared to any other ethnic group.
So that's a community that we are trying to reach out to, to
educate, and to work with partner organizations on how
we can
get out
and ensure those patients understand their risks,
and understand what to look for and what to ask their doctors for.
But I think it's a great question, and it is a
hard problem to solve. I think we're all trying to
do it in our own way based on who our
cancer community is.
And then I think, just as Sharon and
Angie suggested, having patients and a diverse
set of patients at the table
in all discussions, whether we're talking about
policy, whether we're talking about a clinical trial design, whether we're
talking about eligibility criteria,
the challenges that patients face in, "I don't want to drive into the
city and pay for parking. I want to stay local in my
community." All of those things are things I think we're all trying to
address, but these are hard
problems. I know, Sharon, you might have
some thoughts, too.
I really don't, just to echo basically what they said.
But it's really at the beginning,
not at the end. A lot of times, even with clinical trial
design, or just like Angie said, if you need a letter, you're
contacting us like, "Oh, the deadline is at 5:00 this evening."
And we never see the grant,
things like that. But right at the beginning, as soon as
that thought come to your mind,
reach out and start processing, and carry
them along the whole entire way.
Hi. Kim Rhoads, Massey Comprehensive Cancer Center.
I want to thank you all for sharing.
I
just want to make one point, which is, it's not the gaps between the NCI
centers. It actually doesn't matter, and
if the NCI center is close, it doesn't matter.
There's no relationship. People don't go.
I've written multiple papers
looking at and asking the question specifically in California, and looking
at the quality of care and asking if that makes a difference in terms of
survival disparities for racial and ethnic minorities.
And you don't have to be at a comprehensive cancer center, you just need to get
NCCN guidelines, and as a colorectal surgeon, I will just say,
for colorectal, it's pretty basic.
I would say pancreas cancer and breast cancer
I think are much more complicated in terms of care, but quality of care
does matter.
Only about 20%,
and I heard 15 yesterday, percent of people use comprehensive cancer
centers. So they should not be the target for trying to improve
the quality of care,
because you're going to get more bang for your buck if you go for the other 85%
where people are getting care. And that sort of brings me to this point, because in
one of our studies, we showed that people will drive farther than your
cancer center to go to a place that has a lower quality of care because
that's where the relationship is.
Just want everybody to sit with that for a second.
Can you repeat that?
Yeah. So
my last name is R-H-O-A-D-S. So if you want to read any of these
papers, they're in the literature.
One of them, we looked at what is the explainer for
people driving past NCI centers and for
people going to non-high volume centers, which also
have good outcomes, and it's really about the neighborhood.
So you're like your neighbor. You go where your neighbor goes.
Even though that neighborhood may be within five miles of your local
NCI center, people drive past thatTo go
where they have a relationship.
So is that... I was just going to ask, is that an opportunity maybe for
the comprehensive cancer centers to use patients
to help build community or some way to tap into
the patient populations so that there can be more of a sense
of community or a neighborhood feel?
I know they're huge
institutions, but for the people that do work in them,
that type of study and that statistic might
help them to see where patients can help bridge that gap.
Yeah, and that's actually what I was going to ask Ms.
Sharon to comment on because the T-shirt downstairs says,
"Cancer research saves lives," and as I walked by it, I thought to myself,
"It only saves lives if the results leave the building."
Mm-hmm.
And then the results have to get to where the actual people are.
So I used to be at UCSF, which is why I have this California lens, but
now I'm in Richmond, and Ms. Sharon, Petersburg is not that far
from Richmond.
Sure.
And so I wonder if you could speak to,
and I don't know if you guys heard it, but Petersburg is like a US
hotspot.
US hotspot, and I think it's colorectal and prostate if I'm not
mistaken.
Yes. Mm-hmm. Yeah.
So my question is, what do you think is happening in
Petersburg? And I think these are the questions we're not asking
because this is what you would know.
You just told us you live there, you have family who live there, you can move in
and out of the neighborhoods in a way that institutions
cannot.
Mm-hmm.
And so I'm wondering what you think is going on in Petersburg.
And then the other thing I want to point out, because I've been working with
nonprofits for more than 30 years,
some have lots of resources.
Often, the distribution of not care, low
resource, low income, et cetera, looks the same for the nonprofits who are
working in the spaces where the people are facing the same thing.
And so I just want to think out loud about how do nonprofits who
have big resources and big war chests partner with
smaller nonprofits that are probably serving the areas,
Ms. Sharon, that you're serving. So that's a question for you and a
question for...
Okay. Mm-hmm.
All right. So in Petersburg, of course,
the nearest major hospital would be in Richmond.
So that's one thing. The highest mortality rate,
but what is really missing, I would say, is
education. We need more education
down there. I come from a financial background.
I
didn't like science at all in school, only
dissecting the frog, okay? That's it.
And I'm like, "Ew."
So I was teaching a class down there, and someone raised their
hand because I told how we first got started, and
they said, "Can you explain to me what is a clinical trial?"
And I was shocked, and someone else said, "Yeah,
can you tell us about this clinical trial?" So we left from
finance
to start talking about cancer and clinical trials.
Some of the things we hearing is that, oh, the TV is too fast.
If you mention a drug or cancer,
it's going too fast for someone to process it.
But we definitely do not have enough boots
on the ground where we are doing education.
You have to continue to do it. We did a
program, Teach One, Reach One, and Teach One is
about,
well, I'm not of that age, but if I teach you
about it, you can tell your neighbor, you can tell the
next person, your teacher. So you constantly have
to be down there.
Petersburg made the front newspaper are the
highest crime, highest everything in the state of
Virginia. So people are skeptical about
going down there. I don't do too much night
down there,
but I can go in there, and I can easily
say, "Hey, we have different types of T-shirts." One of our
T-shirts said, "Did you get your butt checked?" And it's a big old butt on
that T-shirt. Now, I can say that, but someone from
that community have to be very careful if
they come and say that. If they not from that
community or if they do not look like they from that
community. So I think that's different, but the main thing is
educate. I would clearly say the number one thing is
knowledge is powerful, and the knowledge is just not
there. So you have to, when you say meet people where they are,
you actually have to go there. So that's
it. And just like you said, with the nonprofits, it's
exactly the same,
for funding and things like that. So...
And I always, Sharon, love your messaging on things,
but also we talked about cancer vaccine trials and
cancer or trials in general, and you said, "Do I look like a guinea pig?"
Because there is this perception
that somebody's experimenting or that it's
only a last resort type of thing to do.
And so I think that's where patient advocates are also
trying to educate on what is
a clinical trial.
Right.
Why should people sign up? What are you giving
back if you do that? And what are the risks or not risks to
you in that? And so that's a role I think you play really beautifully.
Yeah. One of the things
IBring up Henrietta Lacks,
Tuskegee, and guinea pig right from the start.
I don't allow you a chance to bring it up because I know
it's going to come into play. When that happened, that did
happen. So when that happened, they did not have any laws in
place. They did not have anyone that looked like me where
you're sitting on the NIH board or any of these boards. Now they do.
So we are your voice, so you can tell us
if medication ain't working, side effects, if you feel your
doctor's not listening, you can call the FDA and report different
things. So it all still goes back to
education, and a clinical trial is not a
last resort. I'm early stage, and again, I'm in my fifth one.
The one that I'm in now has nothing to do with cancer,
but I'm still in a clinical trial. So not only do
I talk the language, I walk the walk, and I still
show up. And in Petersburg, you
must show up quite a lot, not
just when you need something.
It's a parade. What are we doing in a parade?
What does a parade got to do with cancer?
It'll give me a voice to talk. Stop the
violent rally. I'm going to show up.
I just got a text, "Hey, Pastor So-and-so is having his
anniversary." If I'm in town, we will show up.
So they'll know who to call. You have to pound
on... It's like a little kid when they ask, "Mom, can I have something?"
"No." They keep asking. "Here. Here you go."
So you always have to show up. Just don't show up when you need something.
You have to build that trust with a
trusted messenger. One thing, and I'll be real
brief because I know you're waiting now.
Oh, no.
We built a great relationship with the sheriff department.
Now, she has a nonprofit, and she's a breast cancer
survivor. Her whole sheriff car has breast cancer all over
it. Here's the beauty of that. When we want to do
something, she can send out a robocall to everyone, and
they'll show up. So that's less work for us because
we have partnered with someone that knows how to get
the community out.
Yeah. No, that's great. I was actually at a meeting last week, and we were having a
very similar conversation to kind of back to your question about how do the
national organizations partner with organizations like
yours. You know that town better than anyone else, right?
And you can't just go in as a national organization and expect we're going to be
able to do the right things with that community.
And we just talked about the challenges of that, that there is not a very good
system in this country for even knowing.
I know now about Sharon, but I didn't know about Sharon before I came in here.
And so, right, how do you
find that landscape of all these little organizations
doing a lot of amazing things in their communities and find the ones that
are the right ones to partner with?
So I think it is the right thing, and that's what we should be doing, but the
system doesn't make that incredibly easy.
Thank you all, and thank you, Dr. Rhodes, for standing up.
I missed your session yesterday. I'm going to go watch it on demand because I heard
it was great.
I'm Jennifer Loukesis. I'm at the National Cancer Institute.
I'm not a scientist. I do
science communications and public affairs work, and
I am helping to write up what they're going to do for the Cancer
Therapeutic Vaccines
public-private partnership, which is in partnership with the
Foundation for NIH. So it's a 50/50 share, and
we're going to be, hopefully, in the next couple of months, having something
formal to announce. So I didn't know that it originated with you guys.
That's really cool. Anyway,
so I have a couple things I wanted to
share. One is that, it's great that you guys have a call
line. The National Cancer Institute also
has a
call line. Can you still hear me? Okay.
Mm-hmm.
We can. Yeah.
So 1-804-CANCER is a great place to go if you're looking for information
about clinical trials. I love that you said it's not a last resort.
Clinical trials are the way that we
advance medicine, and so thank you for
saying that. The other thing I wanted to say to the PIs in the room is that
the National Institute on Minority Health and Health Disparities
is open for business, is taking grant applications, and
there's a misconception that that institute doesn't exist, and it
does, and I please, I urge you when you return home to your
institutions, that you tell your colleagues that they should submit
applications for grants.
I have some cards if people want to connect with me after.
I'm happy to connect with anyone. And I also just want to say, these
meetings, I've been coming to this meeting for 18 years, and they didn't use to
have patient advocate sessions, right?
They have started, last five, six, maybe even a little bit more.
So this is a place where you guys should be meeting each other, and it's one of the
things that's my favorite thing to do is to bring folks together.
So
anyway, thank you for listening, and
thank you for sharing all of this.
Again, thank you for what you're doing.
I would say,
we would've hoped for a better turnout, so thank you all for coming because
patient advocates are still not appreciated as a part
of the process. And
I've been asked to speak.
I was on a panel last year with Dr. Rothbaum and
Bertagnolli, and I have
imposter syndrome sometimes of how am I on this
stage? But at the same time,
you can't do your job without us, without the patients.
And so,
when I hear about clinical trials that didn't enroll,
and they had to cancel because they couldn't get patients into them, at
the same time, I'm getting calls every single day
by multiple patients who want to get
into trials. There's a disconnect, and I really think the patients,
patient advocates, are the ones who can close those gaps.
So I would hope that as we continue to do more of these panels,
there will be a wider audience, and those conversations
will continue so that we can help to enroll
those trials. We can help to get them started faster.
We can do the consent so that we're sure that it's
accessible to patients. We can help go out into the
communities or design the trials so that
they're going out into the communities to make it easier for people to
participate. So, thank you for what you're doing, and
communications is a big part of it, and that's really the
only reason why I thought I could play a role in
any of this, is because I had that skill of communicating, and I was hoping that
that maybe was the missing link. And
so far we're making good progress, so thank you.
So real brief, because I know people are waiting to ask questions.
One thing that I see is that when a person mention a clinical
trial, they don't talk about the good benefits.
For example, cancer, chemo, radiation surgery,
over 100 appointments, and then you're just dropped.
When you want to be monitored really well, that's one of
the benefits right there.
If it's a drug on the market that's not open to everyone,
and it's so many types of clinical trial.
So once you get the person involved, maybe it's a
financial clinical trial, maybe it's an exercise clinical
trial. Once they believe in that,
why am I in number five? I truly believe
clinical trials and research. So
that's it.
Thank you all for a great panel. Ben Zeskin from ImmuniRing.
I wanted to get your input on quality of life and sort of the role
that patient advocacy organizations can play in quality of life.
And the reason I bring that up,
we have a drug in phase III for first-line pancreatic cancer, and
we have great survival data, but we also designed it to have
really strong tolerability and to help patients maintain and gain weight.
And people get so focused on just
tumor shrinkage by itself, right? How much did you shrink the tumor?
And ours shrinks the tumors. It does it slowly and durably as opposed
to a short, rapid, temporary reduction,
which is ultimately better for the patients.
But is there a role or a voice for patient
advocacy organizations in really advocating for quality of life and
saying, "Hey, it really matters if a drug doesn't cause
horrific rashes or nausea or vomiting or diarrhea," right?
That really matters to patients. And we hear from the investigators that it does,
and we hear
incredible stories from the patients that the tolerability matters, maintaining
weight matters. But
how can patient advocacy organizations help to put quality of
life a little more in the forefront of how drugs are
evaluated together with survival, of course?
You actually have to invite us in
right at the beginning.
Okay.
And we definitely can tell you, "No, this is
not good," whatever. I'm 11 years out, and
I have permanent nerve damage in my feet. It left my hand.
But 11 years, it did get better.
My quality of life is excellent. I just keep
moving. Now, some days I do have to stop, and the
socks or the shoes doesn't feel right, or it can be 90
degrees, and I have on boots, and people think I'm
crazy. But for patient
advocate group, we do advocate for the quality of
life. But again, it's right at the
beginning, or if we're on panels at
FDA and things like that, and a grant may
come through or whatever. We'll look at all that.
But it goes back to
connect to patient advocate groups right at the beginning,
and we can help with that and give you feedback on
that.
Yeah. Nobody's better to tell us than the patients themselves as to what is
tolerable and what's not. And I think every patient is different too, right?
For some people, I remember a doctor saying the
patient played the violin, and that was really important to them.
So having neuropathy was not a good option for that
patient, right? So that they chose a different drug.
Those are the kinds of information that we should be
telling patients so that they can make an informed decision about
their care and understand what the impact is going to be.
And I think the nuances between the cancers are really important.
When you start talking about quality of life and the response as far as
balancing durability versus quality of life.
For colorectal cancer patients and breast cancer patients and pancreatic patients,
that quality of life question is different because we go through different
experiences. So I do encourage our industry
partners to bring patients to the table.
But also, if you're going to ask for PROs, if you're going to ask
questions and survey patients on that, having that actual feedback loop
back to say, "Did you actually change anything?
Given you're asking these questions and you're looking at quality of life, what are
you doing to amend the treatment plan or dosage to
address it?" So I think it's incredibly important.
I think that most of us are keenly aware of those challenges
post-treatment.
I would also say as a company, that's a wonderful thing for you to
get out, that you care about quality of life, and that that's what
you're either designing for or what came from your
research. Because as you probably know, there's an impression
that
Big Pharma doesn't care.
They see us as numbers.
Yeah.
And so to be able to include the patient voices
in whatever you're doing, I would just say would be a huge
benefit to your company as well as to the patients.
At the beginning.
It's a goal from the start.
Yeah.
That's pretty kind of nice. Thank you very much.
Thank you.
I think we have
two more questions, and I think we're going to wrap up the-
I just had a quick announcement.
Oh, okay.
Which is AACR,
yeah, is catching up now. I think some other
big meetings are catching up to the idea of having patient
advocates. I want to point out SOCOE, the Science of
Community Outreach and Engagement, S-O-C-O-E.
It was started by a group of COE leaders in NCI cancer centers
across the country. I'm one of them.
And,
we
typically welcome about 200 people to our annual meeting, and at
least 50 of them are patient advocates. We have a patient advocate track.
We have altered our content delivery so that the patient advocates are not
always separated from the actual content delivery.
There's always a patient advocate on the panel, or
moderating, or the whole panel is patient advocates.
And AACI, which is the American Association of Cancer Institutes,
basically approached us to talk about trying to create a
national network of patient advocates and community
partners. So we are sort of fueling that for them.
We put on quarterly webinars to try to keep people together as we
move toward the next conference. Next conference is in Detroit.
It's
May
6th through 8th, and
I hope to see some of you there.
Yeah.
Tell people to come. And then we'll be in North Carolina
next year in May, and then we'll be at Massey in Richmond
in our final year of the grant funding.
But we hope to continue because we think we're setting the standard for how
the meeting actually feels like it's about...
That the science really is pointed toward impacting
patients and families and the whole
ecosystem.
Can you say that again, SOCOE?
S-O-C-O-E, and the website is
socoalliance.org.
That's a great announcement. Thank you.
Yeah.
Yeah. Okay. So I'm here at
AACR. I work for a contract research organization.
So none of the drugs are mine. It's all about getting other people to get their
stuff done better, faster, smarter.
But I'm not here,
in this session, and actually in the
COE session, was it last night or... It's blurry.
It's another evening one.
More on a personal capacity as a science educator and
advocate there. So speaking to clinical trials, my grandmother
had pancreatic cancer. She happened to be diagnosed when I was in
grad school at a hospital,
teaching hospital, nursing hospital, and grad
school. So it was literally in the same building
where I was doing my thesis work on
HEMOC. So I could go downstairs and be with
her at the appointments and with chemo and everything
and be a medical translator. So I often tell my
mother that I am not that kind of doctor.
But I'm still the official medical translator for the family.
And so
really highlighting the value of the trusted messenger.
So someone who knows enough to understand
the gibberish that is coming out of the people in the coats, to be able to
translate it so the patients can actually
make those informed choices of, "Okay, maybe I want to try this.
Maybe I don't want to try that drug because I need to play a string instrument, so
I need to be able to feel in my left hand, or
it's not worth it for me."
Being mindful of meeting people literally where they are, and actually you have to
be there or you aren't trusted. It's like, who is this guy
who shows up every once in a while when they need some letters of support for some
grant, then we don't hear from them for five years?
It steps on your own credibility. So
definitely reinforcing that, and
a lot of what I do in my day job is essentially teaching.
So talking clients through various options, maybe
bringing them up to speed. They're experts on one thing, but here's what we're
doing.
Mm-hmm.
So there's a lot of transferable skills and a lot of things that make a lot of
sense. So forming those panels where you have patient advocates up there,
it's like, yes, they don't have an alphabet after their name for this
specific thing,
but there's a lot of useful transferable skills and experience
that's valuable. So the
total is worth more than the sum of the parts.
So really seeing things like this, I'd love to see it a little more full, but
so be it. It's still significant progress from where...
I've been coming to ACR for longer than I want to admit.
It's significant progress in the last several years, so it's great.
Awesome. Thank you.
Thank you.
So I'm Patty Spears. Hi, everyone.
I think I know everyone from Julie, but
Sharon, nice to see you.
Hi.
But I'm a patient advocate at Lineberger COE.
I'm the advocate in there.
ACR has
really done a lot for advocacy, with the Scientist Survivor
program, and then actually we did a session right before this
that is based on abstracts that are submitted.
Because I think ACR is the only big meeting. Hi, Stephanie.
Is the only big meeting that has a category for
patient and community engagement.
And my session that I did before this, we
base it on who submits. So if you want to get on stage and have
a say, and we used to do ours at 6:00, and now we get 5:00.
Or 3:00. We get 3:00 to 5:00 instead of 5:00 to 6:00.
So the more you do it, the more you can go further.
And I think ACR, I give them credit for doing that.
They test things out, and then they move things around.
And I think it's really important to say that this was really
important, and to get the word out that getting this stuff out to
everyone, especially to researchers, is really, really important.
And to submit abstracts and to submit
stuff to the...
So if you submit abstracts, you get a poster for sure, usually, and then you might
get a speaking engagement as well.
And it's the only meeting, I think, that does that now.
And I think COE is like at many different-- The comprehensive cancer
centers have CCCIF, and so I'm really interested in your meeting.
CCCIF actually in their outline on
the SOBO 2025, they said, "Use the SOBO 2025 themes," things like
that. So if you saw CCCIF put a page
together again.
Oh, I did that.
It was at the end of the day that this-
Yeah.
So I won't encourage anybody-
But we need more community members.
But we did a virtual
breakout,
brainstorming thing, I think with Sharon on it. I think you were on it.
I don't remember. But we did a thing, what is meaningful engagement?
And then we had a patient panel at the meeting in North Carolina,
because we did it at North Carolina.
But I hope that they do it every year.
But I think having two meetings is weird.
But it's kind of like an opportunity for more,
and we get our patient and our community members involved because we think
the community is so important and the nonprofits in the community, like what
Sharon does,
is so important. Boots on the ground is extremely important, and that's what
COE does. COE is boots on the ground, so really excited.
Really excited that this-
Mm-hmm.
This-
I love the plug to five stars for this panel.
That's the plug, right?
I give it five stars.
So, no, I really appreciate everybody engaging in the
discussion. Kristen, I'm so glad you made it.
I'm sorry.
No, no, no.
I'm so sorry.
I'm glad you're here. I really am. And really, congratulations to everybody for
all the hard work. I actually wish this had been a round table so we could've just
had a discussion-
Yeah
... rather than a panel, and maybe that's something that we can share.
But I thank everybody for being here, I know it's late in the
day, and staying engaged and asking great questions and sharing your knowledge with
us. So thank you so much.
Thank you.